[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys you guys should be
able to hear me
you should be able to
i don't know why mike monitoring is on
but we're going to change that
give me one second
all right you guys i shouldn't be able
to hear myself anymore
why can't i still hear myself
it's muted
no
what is going on
i hear an echo
all right
all right
you guys should be able to hear me now
i don't know what was going on i had to
like close out of all the stuff there
was somewhere that it was open and it
was making me hear it twice somewhere
it was open
what's up carl uh they shouldn't be they
can't hear you yet
uh i i went ahead and uh decided to to
stream it on the iop channel people was
asking uh so i went ahead and dated the
uh
what people was asking like a lot of
people was asking
well they just they some of them said
they didn't want it they didn't want to
go to twitch or something like that and
i figured since it's something like halo
like you know
it's it's best not to lock something
like that down but um
uh let me go ahead and uh
forte's supposed to be showing up here
you know how sometimes he is
no they can't they can't hear you
because my because my desktop's not on
but i'll go ahead and put you on
uh it goes in
to this all right they should be we
should tell the people on twitter that
it's not gonna be on twitch i did okay
okay
let me let me let them know it was good
yeah i did
i just like i i was streaming i was
doing like a free stream playing a
persona and people was asking are you
guys going to stream it on on the iop
channel and i was like you know what
like this this is something serious so i
can understand why people would want it
on youtube and that's where our
following is
all right so whenever you're ready to uh
to get on camera just tell me
all right give me a second
um
what are we doing the um
the the official xbox
um xbox youtube i mean yeah
yeah we'll definitely do it there
all right no doubt
what's going on around
chilling chilling they get me yeah they
can hear you now no doubt what's going
on
thomas
you know what i'm saying hold on let me
get this giant over here what about the
windows at
i'm all type of messed up this morning
give me one second
uh
let's see i gotta hit back prince
gotta open up our joint there we go
yo what's up who calling me boom you
can't be calling me boy it's a string
i got a texture to say no shout out to
boomstick xl the homie
[Music]
ali what's
up
oh man
so
uh let me call forte because he said he
wanted to do this
yo george is stupid he said god got that
morning breath right now how are you
gonna do me with the morning breath
though damn
it's waking up you know what i'm saying
i might have just woke up
yeah see look look that's how much we we
could give you guys that content man we
wake up when we have no business being
up to give you guys
wow this is a big one are you coming
forward
yeah yeah lord metro said car got
detroit
one second
oh man i'll say
i thought he was doing a joint
listen on
tw
twit twit
i mean twitter dm
i'm going to type a message up this
morning this halo better be fire got me
up early
that's that's what i'm saying like it
better be here i gotta be doing special
things halo
almost nine in the morning right now
halo what's going on
we're definitely doing too much let's
just hit me with the light because
bulldog went in man it's a big moment
you know what i'm saying for the culture
i mean hit me with me with the link all
right what link
the um to join joint
we
we we in discord there's not a lien oh
that's right i'm bugging i'm about to
see i'm all type of messed up today let
me get him to join he's just gonna have
to join another one and we're gonna have
to drag him in here
join another one another let's go no
join any of the chats like the call chat
or something and we can drag him in this
chat oh hold on we're on disco homie
you know
oh
he should be part of the
you have to have certain privilege to
come in this one
yeah i know the thing is
oh man let me send him an invite to the
server i thought he was proud a part of
the server already
boom got me doing work in the morning
what's going on folks
all right
let's get this over to my maze mr
bullstick excel
here we will talk to you guys
momentarily we're gonna i'm gonna mute
all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
what's going on stop showing what's up
how you busa what's up dev singer what's
going on
my voice you guys are philly eagle well
actually you know it's probably best uh
yeah
check that out
yeah
kick off time about to be right
hello salute
that's sir adam what's up chrono what's
up dustin lamb they said boobs here
that's right [ __ ] excel hollow
what's going on my
channel said don't tell work i'm here
listen
what you do
just don't get fired brother just don't
get fired yeah all right
what's up man
be a cool story to say i got fired for
halo though
yes that is true jd let's go
yeah
what's going on
sean hamilton what's up what's going on
what's up skyline what up 9 lives what
up oh everybody's up here early
yeah well listen come on it's it's the
king it's the king of shooters that is
true i'm saying that's true ham solo
where's david um him in jamaica jim ryan
is out somewhere right now they was
partying on the boat somewhere so i
don't know
i'm trying listen just just a little uh
you know um uh advertisement 12 30.
check it out uh my channel i'm trying to
assemble the avengers i call this out so
uh
i wanted to get out of everyone's way
let everyone do their thing and i'll
come in hot uh two shows you're getting
today from double barrel games 12 30.
what are we getting are you coming back
tonight for prime time and uh
uh it's going to be good let's go
yeah that's what's up brother oh you're
working man you're always working
drawing tj so so we all oh wow y'all
coming in are you coming in hot all
right you're gonna put that kid up but
you're gonna put that camera
in the giant
all right do you like how the overlay
looks yeah that's what say what uh
hololens welcome to the bronze realm
brother so mo silver king with the one
pound seventeen pants what's going on
say something brother then we got we got
what else element of po five dollars in
the jab what y'all all doing here i
wonder
you already know let's see let's see we
got drawn tj draw tj you got to be
fulfilling cause i heard that
philly dude say draw five dollar super
chat morning guys at work gonna have to
rely on your reactions
no doubt
oh man belkin
ragnar it looks like with the 10 hour
canadian love the channel lords always
appreciate your input on these things
you guys made 2017 e3 for me and my
buddy much love from canada yo salud
falcon rad do you like those do you like
how i have that j file chat again i'm
i'm do excited halo's back yeah do you
like how i have the overlay code yeah i
like it i like it i'm feeling it you got
the um your bottom bar though but it's
cool yeah well i can't do nothing
because it's not a video yet like right
right right oh yeah because it ain't
yeah full screen you ready right right
do your thing brother do your thing one
minute uh wait a minute one minute to
show time did they say how long this was
going to be i think it's a very shallow
benji yeah benji said it's supposed to
be six to ten minutes long
all right that's fine
a little short listen
what they need to do is exactly what
sony did you give us you know uh you
know i mean sony's went a little long
like 13 minutes they would show but you
give me 10 minutes of of of anything
halo oh uh
oh good
now we got the two minutes we got the
the go on to go on
yeah hurry up and wait
yeah now you guys don't hear the music
in the background right i don't hit
yours yeah i'm gonna keep it muted till
it actually starts
yeah you you're good
um
you're watching it from the youtube
stream right yes yes yes all right cool
so we'll make sure what's your time
right now
yeah 134 133 okay cool
make sure
stop showing what up
yeah i got 130 exactly cool cool uh
skyline
gamers talk sports podcast files with
chat what's up lords i'll be there later
too boom one love
thank you sir
that's what's up
appreciate that very much nano designer
i'm just
i was at work at two o'clock in the
morning i ain't at work right now okay
oh my man fozzie he said on why is
youtube fuzzy and twitch is clear
lords yes yes bredrin what's up
30 million
just thought i'd gameplay you here oh
dude thank that's very kind to you
brother i appreciate that i truly do
best of this trend here comes the boom
man that that that
that countdown they do is so intrusive
man it's so like loud like
yeah
yeah i have my this is it fellas 25 all
right i'm trying to get up
turn it up let's do it 117 we're here
y'all know what we're here for let us go
to chief the campaign the highly
anticipated
let's see what they do oh
rated t for t since the beginning
halo was about master chief and cortana
partners protecting humanity
but that is now a distant memory
humanity is fighting for survival
the banished have risen defeated our
heroes
and taken control of the mysterious zeta
halo
we need a savior
we need hope
we need spartan 117 master chief
don't play the music
ghostbusters
you said turn up the stream a little bit
attic
turn up the stream
yeah enjoy the run turned up all the way
hold on are you good
yellow now
in the biggest campaign to date halo
infinite invites players to become
master chief and discover true spartan
freedom in the most wide open and
adventure-filled halo experience yet
but chief won't be alone on the journey
his first mission is to retrieve a new
ai codenamed the weapon
it's been six months where have you been
following the events of halo 5 master
chief is searching for the answer to a
troubling question
what happened to cortana
i was created to lock down cortana but i
don't know why
what did she do that was so wrong
order received standby
oh that's cool he's saying he brings you
stuff
oh that's dope yeah
oh
give me some help make this game the
banished our hunting master chief and
the remnants of the unsc victory is
already banished army is spread across
the surface
building fearsome strongholds and
outposts with no one to stop them
until now
yeah
but
what if it's a friend
it isn't
it is
okay
big boy business
freedom than ever before to take down
the banished any way they choose
banished facility up ahead chief
some kind of salvage operation
what do we do
ubisoft helped make this game i promise
you
he said what do we do
pull out the rocket launcher and get off
they got outposts like ubisoft does
yeah but i mean if you want an open
world you have to kind of do it that way
that looked like a halo 5 boot to the
side y'all yeah it sure did
do you see that could be useful
if you like that kind of thing
oh i like it
allows us all to be cool
the sandbox in this game is ridiculous
and surprising new threats like the
antique wheels skimmers
skimmers
spartan killer named jega or domni
barton killer
you are not the future
exploring this vast and fractured world
will put spartan 117 to the ultimate
test
but where there is courage
there is hope
welcome to the new era of halo
oh
is everyone trying to kill us this is
something it kind of seems like i think
i think so
[Laughter]
okay
play it day one with game pass
interesting
you got textures on his face now
let's go let's go
well we thank you fellas
i mean i mean
first of all what could you say then
uh this was the best way it was
controlled right
they showed what they wanted us to see
right this wasn't done on a live stage
this was this obviously recorded this
was done honestly i i'm really looking
forward to the 4k upload which i'm going
to watch again yeah the show at 12 30.
for sure folks i mean
he jumps out of out of a vehicle
and flies down to shoot one with a
rocket launcher and then harpoons
another one and kicks the guy out
what could you what could you say first
of all i'll tell you this and i'll let
everyone else speak in a second let's go
um
here's five got a lot of criticism for
the openness right
now
i didn't criticize it for that one of
the the criticisms that i have tipped my
hat to was it was open but it's a little
empty right this does not seem
like that yeah i think i agree 100 with
attic it almost seems as if they got
help from somebody at ubisoft because
this i mean i'm playing through far cry
right now and it literally looks uh i
mean it's halo right it looks like far
cry
some marines broken down over here that
are under fire go take on this base i i
think that is going to open up because
again we're going to be following a
story so we're going to have those close
quarter
encounters
that's going to make it feel like halo i
love what i saw i don't know about
everybody else no doubt forte what up
what to do man what you thinking brother
yeah man
oh oh we lost them
yeah someone was calling me oh
yeah i agree 100 i think in general um
they definitely look like they got help
from some other studios um far cry is
definitely a good one but it just seems
like they're expanding that sandbox to
be something way more than it's ever
been when it comes to halo like i got
like a lot of just cause speech stuff
from it like
you like you can like if you see it you
can do it
especially with the grapple hook being
in the game you can get to places that
you could never get to before and it
just screamed like a sandbox that you
could just toy around in that actually
has a structured uh narrative that's
gonna um kind of bring you back in when
you get to certain parts of the game so
it's like yeah that's the one thing that
i know it's like we're gonna take you on
a ride that's gonna like take you to
different places and stuff on site um on
the zeta halo
but if you get out of those narrative
parts the the whole ring is your oyster
you could do whatever
no
doubt adequate yeah i like it
i i really enjoy a lot of stuff that
they showed i'm about to show the screen
a little bit um they should see it now
if you guys want to you can uh look at
the stream i want to like focus a little
bit on this rpg
tree like this
thank you
so
if you notice here
you got the grappling hook so there's
multiple different grappling hooks now
um i'm seeing like it's kind of weird
like
one would think there was isn't a lot of
way that you can
make upgrades for a grappling hook maybe
like an extender like a like a like a
like a hook shot on zelda or make it go
longer
that was for me that was because low-key
it's highlighted on it on the right
impulse adds significant power to the
thrust and allowing further and faster
travel
so
if you look above that it's the drop
wall one yes uh where it is where you
could put the shield down it looks like
one's like a defense thing
uh
one's maybe adds on a time frame then
you got the threat sensor so you can
upgrade that as well now let's look at
the top the fob and target so it looks
like they brought like kind of that
ubisoft assassin's creed where you have
certain targets that you have to fight
uh so it looks like you know you'll be
able to go around and get that i want to
know what this fob is
yeah which i think that fob is that's a
good question i don't know
i don't know it's kind of interesting i
i'm a huge fan of the ubisoft thing i
got it
thumbs up thumbs up okay
that's big from you because you you
you're very particular when it comes to
your halo i don't want to hear no one
say hey loonies do something different
they literally just completely changed
the entire sandbox effect
you know where i knew it was on some
next level stuff cog is when he jumped
out shot the with the repub with with
the spike gun killed the the the driver
in it then grandpa looked on the go on
the banshee got in the banshee look like
the sandbox is fun like yeah i never
thought that
i never thought the sandbox could be
manipulated the way they have done this
now i i do want to bring out one more
person uh that i thought it was
interesting because you could tell they
were showing the scene
you could tell they were doing the
sandbox but then they did this
this
where it's whoever this is yo oh that
the spartan killer oh no not the spartan
she said so
she says that she is she's clearly not
uh she might be forerunner i mean she
kind of looks like a little bit of
forerunner but she's quite declaring
four runners are liars so like maybe
she's the four runner enemy like yeah
it's good you know there's some kind of
core in the middle of here in the middle
know what she's using here this is
something new if it seems like like some
type of power it's interesting what i
like is they showed you this is the
world you're gonna play it this is the
world that you're gonna you're gonna
have fun in i could see why the game
isn't split screen at launch i can
understand that a little bit more
especially seeing reactors like that
blow up doesn't make it right but it
does i can understand a little bit more
what i like is they show this is what
you're going to play in and it's like at
the end they're like and this is kind of
the story some carpenters something
saying the four runners are lying keep
in mind like right here as you can see
she hits master chief like a football
field away
you are not the future
it's crazy when she said was great let
me jump in man like this drink i think
i'm weird on wait what forte said in the
sense that like
i'm gonna get the negative out the way
and it's not really a negative it's just
more like
this is not a joint that i'm gonna be
like oh my god this is the most
graphical thing i've ever seen it's not
that what this is is this is the
ultimate sandbox i've ever seen this is
the ultimate you do everything in almost
anything in this world to be real with
you when i saw
the slight ubisoft slash rpg mechanics i
smile i'm like okay we can customize we
can make and play in the chiefs style
that i like you know what i mean and
then the other point attic i think you
appreciate it is that you know it kind
of gives me the feel of epic
confrontations with the banish when you
got like it feels like mini bosses right
when you get to certain
it's like a mini ball so you gotta mix
it up and stuff like that i've loved
stuff like that and it that where it
seems like when they're throwing the
narrative portion in so it's open world
sandbox but again with narrative beats
and i kind of like the whole joint where
like you know you out there on possible
odds you could grab up save soldiers
they up in the warthog so it gave me
like halo combat evolved vibes in the
future world with this tremendous
sandbox so
look like our boy said patrick this is a
halo ass hey look
like i just gotta call it what it is
yeah
i don't get it i don't i don't agree
with that like yeah
that gameplay didn't feel like halo to
me like that's not in a bad way it
didn't feel like the standard halo it
felt like halo
on steroids like yeah i didn't say i
didn't i don't mess with being like it's
standing like it's wack i'm just talking
about
like you're saying that the core it's
still halo yes this is halo like this is
what i'm trying to say i'm gonna be one
of when i say the negative is like for a
person who never liked halo i don't know
if you're gonna get that guy to be like
yo you know what i'm saying all of a
sudden they play it but for the core
base and for people who love halo you're
wild you're like yo they are doing stuff
get boom i see you at the gym
you know i i mean i agree but i don't
because here's the thing there is a very
large subset fan base of ubisoft's
quote-unquote style right there's a
specific way
that you know that you're going to play
far cry 6 yes uh assassin's creed and
ghost recon right now some people are
like yeah i i'm that's that's not my
style i wrote og style here's the thing
i actually think
because this game looks and plays like
far cry 6 which is hot right now which
is doing very well was reviewed very
well i have a strange feeling that
people who didn't
mess with
halo because it was too old-school okay
potentially come into this with fresh
eyes and i think that i i think what
they have done is based on and i
remember i'm an og because i i
you know halo combat evolved i think
we're gonna get that with the story
beats but i think where it changes where
we get the new feeling when we get the
new shine is exactly what we saw we
there's gonna be people that are gonna
run through the campaign because that's
all they want to do so yes for me
i'm 50 hours into far cry
and i don't want to beat it like i i i
am out of the world you want to be in
that yeah i just want to go and take i i
just unlocked the achievement for taking
on every base now i'm doing all the side
quests for the peoples even though some
of them are weird i'm taking them yeah
but but that's where i think this
differs and i think and again there's
going to be some criticism i think
there's going to be people that are
going to say this is not my halo the
hashtag no no no no not that not that i
want to go there i don't want to go
this is my feeling i always think about
people outside of me right and i look at
this and i'm like oh my god this is
that's what i'm talking about right here
open world halo you don't say taking
everything back bit by bit and we're
throwing narrative beats between each
day i'm good i'm just talking about a
guy who's maybe not you know who's seen
halo over the years and was like looking
for something so new or whatever
whatever they may walk away and say look
it looks cool but it looks more like a
halo game with a little extra stuff
that's i'm i'm i'm not concerned i'm
curious i know i know where you are
trailer is going to get a new person
who's never really messed with halo like
that to be like you know what um and
maybe i'm wrong but maybe maybe like
because remember a lot of people love
this open world and maybe you're right
in that sense that the far cry guy the
assassin's creed guy may go okay halo
i'm a rock with you now because you're
doing stuff i like so i'm just curious
if people who are hardcore halo you
should have got forte
explaining it good i think i think the
biggest thing is because you're not
wrong but i also think we're kind of
discounting a little bit of
how big the actual halo player base is
like we we look at the last three to
four games and say okay it's done good
but it hasn't been great people a lot of
people fell off because it didn't change
enough
so i think like you're right the big bit
the base itself is going to be thrilled
by what they saw
but but the biggest thing is going to be
is this might be exactly what they
needed to do to bring that bigger player
base back into the game
go ahead just real quick man we got 760
oh wow
hit that like button you guys i
appreciate everyone coming in you guys
coming here in like a wave man like a
weight right if you guys know this man
you see the iron lures podcast
merchandise down there man you guys
noticed that you know because of you
guys we could put it down there i'm just
stating that man i'm stating that you
know if you guys want to go down and
pick up a shirt
no i'm saying i think like i kind of
resonate with boom what he said about
not wanting to beat the game like with
far cry i did the same thing with breath
of the wild like when i was playing
through that game i was 140 hours in
and i did every single side quest in
that game
could win and beat the game probably 50
hours before that but i still did beat
the game because i'm one of those people
like if i'm loving the game i don't want
to beat it until all the content is out
so i waited to the dlc game out for that
game to go actually beat that game yeah
and then it was like this self like okay
this is everything i'm gonna get out of
this game and i'm good it looks like
with halo sister going with this
long-term plan for the game you're going
to be consistently going in and out of
this game and some people need to
probably come to the realization that
you know me and you being destiny people
yeah
they are not going to want they're not
going to want you to stay
in this game forever there's going to be
reasons to leave it and reasons to come
back to it over the course of time and
that seems to kind of be the wave where
it is that you know when season six of
apex comes out people might jump off a
halo to go play apex but again guess
what hey you want to see you want to
continue the story with the vanish you
want to finally see what atriax is going
to be in the 3d form compared to just
the rts
at that point that people will be like
yo
we need to jump back into halo i just
think this then would it be in the free
to play game being on game pass there's
really no barrier to entry oh so i think
that alone is going to let people say
it's a sandbox game that you could
pretty much do whatever you want to do
it but then those there are the points
as long as the narrative points
as long as the narrative points for the
game is on point it doesn't matter what
they do going forward and because my
last point i'm going to say that's what
personally resonated with me all the
samba see like multiplayer
made me so confident in the sandbox
i wasn't even worried and when i'm
seeing chief doing all this stuff i'm
like yeah this is what i envisioned this
is the ultimate play field i'm happy but
for me and i think attic gonna resonate
is i like those confrontations and the
cinematic the lord are talking the chick
you know what i'm saying the spartan
killing all like i want to meet
characters in that world and like have
these epic standoffs and then i like the
banished you know said i i i felt like a
little boss but he was all you hear we
took over this you know what i said like
i i loved all that so that that was for
me that was the guru i was like okay
this is the type of stuff i wouldn't see
from halo and when i had a problem with
like halo 5's fake you know whatever
they were trying to do with day
narrative you know i said yeah you know
say that that's just where i'm at with
it but yeah it was good man it was good
for me it sounds fine a lot of points
for me all i'm curious is i want to get
the consensus from like a person who's
probably never played a halo game who's
never seen it i want to get the
consensus from that guy does that guy go
yo okay halo
oh i'm not i'm just curious okay i i
think also fantastic i think it depends
on how they build this story i like how
they have a literally a litter
a legit
spartan assassin in the game like yeah
yeah i'm kind of curious if they break
on his past like like are they start
like is the banished always been like
this like we just didn't know it because
they've only been in halo wars have they
always trained certain people just to
kill spartans like i'm kind of curious
on how that kind of you know lore is
going to be explored i'm curious how
yeah you know right this random kind of
forerunner looking person just shows up
are they going to build that correctly
or is it
or is it just going to be like a destiny
thing where they don't really explain
stuff and they expect you to sit around
for a few months until actually having
stuff like eventually explained to you
right yeah i believe you're about to
jump in i was going to say that what
this does is it opens up when you talk
about story beats what this does
remember they said 10-year plan now i
know that's taboo we saw that with
destiny and destiny kind of stumbled
with that right they kind of fumbled the
ball
i don't think that's going to be the
case i i think that with joseph staton
returning the king of halo yes sir uh he
is i mean he just wrote a book he just
launched a new halo book
so if you think that the stories for
halo are cannot be done or that you've
read everything and we may not get new
stories he just
uh wrote a book
right
and it's new to the series and he and
and and again this is my personal
opinion i i feel
once the everyone could sit back
get a bit of a breath
out yes people are enjoying it
game pass made millions more play it
than they would have before correct oh
yeah for sure
i think we get an announcement that he
is now has taken over the studio oh
we're going to see let me get a couple
some chats y'all i think he's already
took over the studio to be honest with
you i think unofficially but listen
gentlemen i gotta bounce oh you gotta
run bro you just wanted to jump in i'm
brother i wanted to show you uh you know
i was the iron lords my support come on
i know listen you got 700 people here
please for the love of joe if you're not
subscribed to iron lords you're doing it
straight up wrong you're doing it wrong
and get that double game in and give my
man to 10k because he had 9k he need to
be at 10k he's even putting it down and
putting on the whole community for a
minute so get you behind
[Music]
12 30 p.m eastern standard time hit back
hit my channel we're doing a full
breakdown i'm putting the avengers panel
together and i gotta i go well we don't
listen
to the secret okay
i need to see that controller sir i see
that xbox poke controller behind you sir
i haven't seen let me see that put that
thing up to the camera bro let me let me
see that let me see that um that
controller bro that controller looked
fire you got right behind you boom yeah
that one right there yeah let me see
that controller i ain't seen it oh boy
that's kind of what's inside that little
cyber postage bro
yeah oh that's
and it just so happens
that the pope special edition needler
haloween is coming today i'm going to be
throwing that off live on this oh
i'll put your channel in the chat
brother yo make sure y'all several
hundreds of y'all in here go over the
double barrel gaming hit that like
button hit that subscribe my brother
doing positive things in the community
always helps out thank you for coming
through brother enjoy your day i know
you got six shows lined
up go do your six shows all right
no no let me get these super chat bunty
two dollars super chat to my favorite
podcast enough love and respect uh
cool beanie gaming fight awesome chat
boom excited my brother all the homie
tony bryant five dollar super chat good
morning rp hope we get some updated
craig yes craig was updated he was
looking kind of crispy out there let's
see let's see we got drawn tj my man
follow some chat best damn show and
graphics best halo yet i can't wait to
play with you guys no doubt let's see we
gotta missed a call wow i missed a
couple there's a bunch of people let me
i'll handle them because yeah yeah
please
please
let me see where i was i got
um just bear with me guys i have to
bring it up i didn't expect that let me
be real what you got i didn't expect
this because it's right now
i was like
i need i i need i need to stop like
underestimating our community yeah thank
you all for coming out no promotion and
just pulling up that's lovely we got a
uh 117 uh
uh one
i think that's pounds 1.17 pound from
simma king definitely put stuff in there
if you put stuff in that chat man put
put some text in there man you got gotta
get your bars off man we got elemental
pia with the five dollar super chat what
you all doing here i'm pretty sure that
was before this happened before the uh
the stuff so then we got a five dollar
super chat from drawn tj
morning guys at work going to have to uh
rely on your action reactions i'm pretty
sure you read that but yeah i read all
that one i'm gonna read them all just to
be on the safe side we got a ten dollars
uh ten dollar super chat from uh
bikonian rega gardner i don't know we're
gonna move past that though love the
channel lords always appreciate your
input on these things you guys made 2017
e3 for me and my buddy much love from
canada we got another five dollar super
chat from drawn tj i'm so excited halo
is back we got a five dollar super chat
from skyline gtr
3 4k gamers talk
that that that's a mouthful pause what's
up lords i'll be late i'll be on later
today too boom one love fellas we got a
five dollar two dollar super chat from
uh bun t y you two off my face huh
no i'm just saying his name oh okay
bunty oh okay two off my favorite
podcast enough love and respect we got a
five dollar super chat from combining
gaming i definitely butchered that we're
gonna be right past that boom excited my
brother we got a five dollars from tony
tony good morning iop hope we get some
updated craig i think we're right where
you are now we got a five dollar super
chub from drawn tj
best damn show in graphics best halo yet
i can't wait to play with you guys we
gotta find all the super chat from
lanzio87
okay
same thing as multiplayer focused on
sandbox
yeah they did i can honestly that's the
best that's the best that the sandbox
has ever been in hey look i agree
we got a five dollar sweepstart from bay
area shout out to the lords been before
to halo infinite looks fantastic good
thing forza horizon 5 got me covered
until december the 8th we got a five
dollar super chat from k
as
good morning halo fans halo is back baby
great halo showing and great live stream
with the og's what a way to start the
week we got a two dollar super chat from
elemental p.o knights like this
we
game of the year i'm calling it now it's
not even close
yeah i don't know if they qualify though
because they late they later they don't
say they don't they might be right up
they might be on the day of yeah we got
a two dollar super chat from brit
brigade all right i'm caught up yep
yep bingham yeah you get it and i get
that fob equals fort operating base oh
okay okay
now now we got oh that's what fob made
thank you that's what's up donald tackle
follow some chat they really pulled the
only in battlefield scene in the halo
trailer to tell 2042 i am the captain
now
you know they still fixing big g follow
super chat i think she is precursor they
are original form of the flood owners of
the mantle the four runners betrayed
them and they made the forerunners do we
get some law of cosines in here from
pictures we literally just got some lore
beats right there yeah that was some law
beats right there then we got elemental
po 5 super chat microsoft is showing
investment here 10 year plans versus far
cry yearly franchise good point good
point i like that elemento pio nathaniel
new name five pounds super chat so long
as the game isn't littered with the
ubisoft outpost filler it's fine also
halo sandbox is more versatile than you
i agree but fully agree that you'd be
some outpost that's in there you can
already tell that's in there you can see
it yeah the banner space that that's the
output stuff but the difference is is
people are tired of that kind of formula
on far cry it's debatable if people are
willing to try that kind of formally in
a halo game and it's new to halo which
yeah that's what i'm saying it's
debatable people might actually be with
it because it's in a new it's a new skin
it's something new for that something
new halo
thin vendetta the dark souls homie my
god fought out of super chat god i love
halo infinite looks so much fun cannot
wait for december he got the hands okay
i see you said vendetta they derose five
dollar super chat og halo fans are gonna
complain wow it's what they do okay so
you think the ogs might push back on the
um
after this you can we could check
twitter a
og
little
bit
be i think there's gonna be a lot of
mixed reactions because some people are
gonna expect them had blown off the top
with the campaign they're gonna feel
like they didn't do enough but if you're
a true halo fan this is like the best
evolution of it that you probably were
gonna get of it no doubt rated blade two
pound super chat halo overview when and
where what have i missed bro you just
woke up where you been where rated where
you been at bro this is lit you know
what i said let's go we got
silencer oh i like that thing silencing
with the fight out super chat this about
to be fire as hell yeah then we got
captain captain chats captain shots with
the 10 pound
big hello from the uk guys that extra
year has made all the difference my god
halo looks absolutely stunning and more
importantly fun now i'm with him there
as a big halo fan i'm so happy roll on
december it definitely looked fun i
that's the part of it like it looked
like a fun world to play in for sure you
you wanna know something that i thought
of just stuff we might just read that
super chat i think the one thing because
the one thing that i was super against
was the fact that this game needed so
much done to it that's why i felt like
it shouldn't come out this year i
thought it was another year um
2022
but if they were going to go into the
open sandbox arena
they can spread that game out a lot more
and they could add like they could keep
the same story element yes but
it is a lot easier to just make the
world look fuller by giving you more
stuff to do in the world over the course
of a whole year versus trying to
completely redo a campaign
in the course of that one year so if
that's the direction they went in with
this that was probably the best
direction they could because they could
consolidate it over the course of 10
years versus trying to do it all in one
year to get the game out like they
wanted to so that might be the best move
that they did i will say
that
you know we're all huge destiny fans
here
and i will say that i honestly feel like
the
the sandbox is on another level than
destiny's sandbox like when you when you
play destiny sandbox
it kind of like after a while i'm not
saying it's not after a while because
it's definitely going to be like on here
but when i see your patrol that seems
more that seems more engaging than
destiny's you know what it feels like i
think you nailed it it remember remember
when d1 dropped and we always in the
cosmodrome for the first time right yeah
what the vibe i'm getting i'm very
curious about how this engine is gonna
work is that we are legit gonna get
connectivity between the spaces i'm
curious or is it gonna play
like okay we're in the edz or now we
gotta we teleport over to you know
whatever you don't say nessus so you
know what i mean like i'm very curious
if it's a true
interconnected hub where it's streamed
out and you could just go like real open
world or is it hub where there's the
icons on the map and we're in different
areas right but it does fee i give i
give attic this it does
destiny's destiny we already know what
that is right but it's like i do feel
like this sandbox is very exciting to
see how
expansive it could be and i'm curious it
does feel like
they've they've been they've been paying
close attention to destiny like right
and i feel like
in a lore wise
they could probably stick more to script
than destiny does because sometimes like
that's that you don't know what the hell
they gonna do next like you'll be
thinking all right we're finally gonna
get sad bethune's ending and then they
talk about the cabal for six months like
all right yeah i mean and what you know
what the vibe i got forte is that they
can start they can start doing like with
this type of 10-year plan thing they can
start doing more transformative things
with the world yes right when new story
beats get inserted and maybe an area
opens up or to me there's a i'm getting
excited now on the possibilities
of this world of this ring wait you see
what i'm going for today what you think
that's that's that's the biggest thing
that i'm looking at is like i think
they have the blueprint sitting right in
front of them in the game that's in
gamepad called destiny and how they
actually
evolved the world over the course of
seven years so i think the biggest thing
that they could do is just have a focal
point put on the narrative of the story
yes sure
when we go between these story beats
however long each one is gonna be to get
to the next one
it makes sense like leaving people
wanting more you know
that was the big okay think about it
shout out to squid game on netflix
everybody watched it when you left one
episode you was ready for the next
episode they were setting you up like
crazy and that's kind of where halo
needs to go and i just think ultimately
the way that the sandbox is set up
it's like we're gonna let you have your
meat and potatoes when it comes to
every little thing when it comes to like
once you get to these certain areas
where the campaign's going to kick in
for you you're going to be focused
you're going to be narrowly tight right
on what you need to do but guess what as
soon as you leave out of that area right
everything just opens up let me ask you
a question dude attic what do you think
about this like
we obviously they're gonna have to have
areas and campaign beats to to
differentiate okay this is the next
level this is the next thing you're
supposed to do do you think it's gonna
be a situation
where there'll be areas on the map where
they'd be like you know what like you
play certain games and it'd be like you
know you ain't at level 12 to be over
here yeah i can almost guarantee you
that's gonna be like that
yeah i guarantee that's gonna be that
was that was another thing i think
they're gonna basically not gatekeep you
out of certain areas if you want to go
in there you can go in there
but it's not gonna be a fun time so all
right i'm curious
what i want you gotta do with the chance
i got most of
what i want to do too is because i do
feel like i kind of want to engage like
what's going on on like twitter and
stuff yeah so when we so i'm going to
change the the layout a little bit but i
have i have us on the left and my
twitter on the right
go ahead and take care of those and then
we'll we'll read a couple super chat uh
we'll read some some of twitter shout
out to the homie mods gaming lords
gaming down there my homie with the 10
dollar poland he said i can't wait to
play halo love ilp love you brother
salute man we haven't talked in a while
i got to get you in the realm gamonomics
with the 40 indian rupees salute no
craig this time
no doubt
el nino 10 alice in the chat looks like
grand theft auto halo in test i don't
know what that means to see if
interested to see if people still feel
there's going to be unfinished game
after this came in good point third time
the charm halo is back i do feel they
need to have a conclusive
kind of ending i mean it's obviously
ongoing but something that you feel
satisfied when you beat this
iteration of the campaign right we know
it's ongoing but i'm just curious i do
agree with them on that i want to see
how they how they do that with the
ending joint and then we got hold on
hold on we got him we got el nino and
then the last one cinnamon that again
fought our super chat just to set the
record straight i am an og halo fan
since halo one and i'm loving what
infinite is doing to involve the serious
salute we got the ogs in there no doubt
no doubt salute attic you're pulling up
you're twitching yeah so i saw i got the
twitter you uh you guys
still super chat pixel bit g two dollar
super chat and craig was there and she
says and she says old friends i don't
know
foreign i'm telling y'all i'm done with
destiny seven years time for a change of
delete destiny y'all great show i can't
wait hey man stop lying to yourself
look i'm lying to yourself you ain't
going to delete destiny
until after which questions
will revisit this conversation about
what you are going to have
halo okay that's the vibes y'all got
okay i got the vibes on that little grab
that overworld do what you want to do
you know what i'm saying that's what's
up man let's see what's going on with
twitter alex what's up
let's do this toy to recap real quick so
we got neville here's some more
information apparently on it uh infinite
campaign the core question is what
happened to cortana chief teams up with
a new ial called the weapon which is
kind of interesting that she's called a
weapon like she don't have a name she
could they call her the weapon
uh you'll encounter marines that join
your fights the player is free to choose
how to fight the banished and master
chief can upgrade his abilities and more
that's pretty much what we saw on the
chat uh looks like our friend tim dawg
we say halo infinite training number two
for positive reasons so it's not
trending for negative reasons good point
yup i'm looking at video games trending
right now halo infinite campaign is
trending for sure i will definitely get
to that
uh let's keep going down it looks like
uh obviously our friend jazz already got
that article out wow
not sure halo
not sure halo infinite's campaign looks
like the type of thing i'd typically
find fun uh right now i am super tired
of open world map cleaning stuff and i
think that's actually valid criticism
that's about like that's what i said i'm
curious about the dude who you know i
mean because he's let me know jesse
really a halo guy like that but he loved
the multiplayer which i thought was a
positive sign for a guy that don't rock
with halo saying i love the multiplayer
but there are people who are anti-open
world you know what's funny is
technically i wanted him but i i would i
like to see halo do something different
so for whatever reason this is exciting
but i'm curious to see how they their
head on the map that is that is
interesting
all right yeah
perhaps that's it
oh
i'll make sure i put them in this place
on wednesday
i feel it cold eastwood look at halo
infinite outposts in free roam in an
open world can't wait you know what i'm
saying let's see what else i thought so
if people are asking for the thought
okay pass out to paris now that is what
i wanted to see from a halo campaign
december you can't get here soon enough
no doubt no doubt a lot of the three all
three four threes for the most part dude
like i'm seeing nothing but oh look
uh forbidden west had some uh some
details today isn't that funny
oh yeah
it put some information out yeah
that's kind of funny for the most part
like oh there's a dude look it's the i'm
following the dude i mispronounced his
name
oh my god shout out to our bat oh black
conflict x that's the homie right there
black conflicts x throw it up follow us
to check great show guys halo is back no
doubt no doubt salute what what i'ma do
man since i mispronounced your name case
uh uh
i'm gonna follow you on twitter man i
missed out today i'll follow you on
twitter good dude caught a boom show
yes sir
jaffee
yes
let's go with you
uh
jeff said it was a jab okay let's not
see what jeffy has to say we can't read
the stuff that jeffy's saying
is that is that for tv yeah i i don't
think it's bad i didn't give it enough
time to read it but i don't think we
should read that on uh just give us the
summary of the thought process like you
know what we where we have oh well
all
by the way
uh
this is too early
okay stream live there better be
microsoft yo he cuss it every five
seconds
[Music]
[Music]
i think i don't think he's really
tweeted much since it came out because
like it looked like that was before
the uh obviously there's king
uh halo infinite campaign over a trailer
i mean look you know what we could do
actually let's look up a couple like
random people we don't know yeah shout
out to them on our own chat right now
the black bruce wayne shout out to the
blackberry halo infinite is a result of
halo 1 to 3 fanboys crying about halo 4
and 5 because of things like sprint and
spartan abilities looks like spartan
abilities confirmed in the campaign
overview no doubt all right so we got
alex something i don't know uh can we
just take a moment to appreciate how
amazing the bandage looked
uh then we got um there's a lot i've
noticed that a lot of people i have to
translate love halo
they said look the halo infinite
campaign looks very fun and promising i
saw that they fixed most of the problems
and i'm happy for that i wish they had
this from the main trailer back then and
now it's time to wait for the december
no doubt shout out to
the last word up in the building he said
i still gotta watch it eat get on that 6
17.
said halo infinite looks really good so
as you can see like like mostly positive
yeah look look someone actually uh uh
oh wow shout out to jamie moran 343 you
did it he's trending up let's look at
the top trendings the top trendings are
super positive for the most part you
know what i'm saying when
alex i don't know who this guy is is but
he said he got like four screenshots he
says when you first saw a halo infinite
campaign were you blinded by its majesty
wow that's super trending um and then
they showed that they showing the
bandage face up close and someone put
when three four three responds directly
to the halo infinite graphics criticism
like they're very impressed by the the
model so it looks like it's super
positive reception y'all superpower but
i'll cut you off i
i think this is this is
one of the best outcomes i can have i
saw
nibble said the 4k version is out so we
might have to interview yeah so
i saw i saw some people um you know bg
what did it be
yeah let's get the video it wasn't
negative but it wasn't positive even
either
bg said um
am i the only one who feels that they
are trying really hard to hide the halo
campaign and show as little as possible
that uh that halo campaign overview was
very limited like the other showings i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to call bg
out right here uh to to me
i don't to me i really don't see how
else they could have showed it like they
showed you a lot of gameplay like a lot
of straight up gameplay so to me
my question is at that point
what do you really want you know what
i'm saying yeah i mean they're going to
show a snippet they're always going to
hold back something they want to give
too much away shout out to slow mo with
the eyeball emote emoji say oh this is
where 40 is
your dps podcast is calling you out sir
he said that's all that's when you ask
shout out the order for all the homie on
what's up man follow some chat two words
it's time
no doubt absolute salute yeah i just
noticed that slo-mo he actually did a
stream today he didn't tell me i didn't
know he was doing one i was asked here
first before i knew he was doing what
so i mean we're going to go ahead and uh
we're going to end it on that uh because
it looks like discord is frozen but uh
you know i definitely appreciate it for
coming through man you know we had a lot
more people in here than i thought 800
of you are in here this is insane wow
thank you it really is it's it's crazy
and uh
first off i want to say man uh
appreciate everyone come through here
you guys came in here crazy with the
super chats the likes the views yes uh
you know
be on here man you don't have to be
first off subscribe to the channel
everyone in here that is not subscribed
to the channel click that subscription
button man we do the iron lures podcast
every sunday right now unfortunately
it's 11am because of football uh so
definitely go down there check that out
man i think you guys are gonna really
enjoy uh this weekend and uh you know
appreciate everyone for coming through
man appreciate everything
make sure the brother get his plug no no
i i was just saying mine that that that
was oh i got a jacket i'm just messing
no dell forte man thanks for pulling up
brother where can the fine people find
you what you got going on and like final
thoughts on halo before we close out
with you yeah man i think it's going to
be a a lot of people talking about halo
today i'm just you know respect
everybody's opinions out there because
it's their opinions and everything
that's the facts that's the biggest
thing everybody needs to do
um definitely going to be making a video
on this giving some more thoughts on it
and everything but overall i'm super
stupid
it's going out too hard he said that
benedict arnold better plug deeply
he even got to that point yet
that is a great co-host let me shout out
this little he said if you don't plug
the podcast
people in here you better nick arnold
don't plug your old chat you better plug
the damn pop through the pocket oh my
god dude let me get to the point oh see
this one this is what happened
this is what happens when your best
friend
is also your co-host of a show this is
what happens but yeah shout out to the
homeboy slumber backslap make sure you
check out dps podcast last week which
was on his channel we rotate from week
to week it will be on my channel so i
will plug my channel because that's
where it's gonna be at this week so
gaming forte everywhere youtube twitter
xbox live and playstation uh we talk
about halo stuff over there destiny xbox
all of that cool stuff if you like that
stuff come to the channel and check it
out also dps podcast episode 58 will be
on my channel we will have a ball we
will be talking about this even more
because a lot more stuff you know always
comes out after the fact when we see
these reveals and stuff like that so uh
like i said just respect each other uh
talk about halo enjoy it and we see you
guys in the next stream no doubt let me
get my balls off yo i will just put a
shout out to the home again salute the
boom double barrel gaming the hardest
working man in gaming 16 podcasts per
week
doing so much but get over the boom he's
gonna be doing a lot of things i put his
channel in the description hit that up
man appreciate him coming through last
minute appreciate y'all man 800 in here
no promotion just decided to wake up do
it shout out to attic thank you so much
for waking me up because i had to crush
in my eye in the morning breath and i'm
here but yo at the end of the day you
know like forte said it best respect
everybody's opinion the consensus seems
very positive you know for me i will
leave it in the immortal words of
patrick wren who we had on the iop for
343 to me this is a halo ass halo game
and in a sandbox that i love it looks
like a lot of creativity and the thing
for me that i'm going to love
is those kind of epic encounters those
narrative beats those where you learn
more who is this guy why are they trying
to kill them you don't say the forward i
like the banishes the enemy type and i'm
excited you know what i'm saying it
definitely the future looks bright the
question will be
will they win over the person who really
doesn't play halo who may be curious but
is it enough and i'm curious to see this
but so far
the response pod and graphically i'm
seeing from from the craig situation
when they went up in the background
and people are doing it you know what to
do this twitter is great
they did a very good job marking against
that like they did a really good job
like first they embraced it uh
look look microsoft and you you watch i
know you guys occasionally watch us
a craig
easter egg and halo infinite like yeah
i gotta shout them out i really got
excited at it when i saw
again i go from i want to thrust it the
thruster was for me that was that was
the thing about halo 5 it was i was
struggling to let go you'll say and the
fact that it's an ability in the
campaign and that you can customize your
master chief how i want that's like
those mini rpg mechanics that i like so
i'm excited you know me i've been there
i've been there man i can't wait
campaign y'all let's do it but that's
all i got man get a bus get us up out of
here yeah we're gonna go ahead and take
out man i'm gonna hit you guys with that
outro man we're gonna no doubt that the
outro
pigs
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]